galabru fitr comédien et adaptateurs une
autre héritière cherche à nous échapper
galabru fille jeune première je vais lui
laisser son petit haut comme ça pour ce
politologue
en coulisses le fils agrafes le père vis
tu as et costumes d'autrefois forcément
maintenant sfo a string mais voilà
devant luzardo pisse-vinaigre match où
tout le monde tremble à michel galabru
se délecte de ce soir en bourse depuis
plus de 40 ans de quoi vous plaignez
vous est ce que j'ai à te voyons bon le
voilà qui monte sur ses grands chevaux
le front de me demander une sortie
remarquée en avignon il crée la pièce
d'équipement noël genod première de
l'époque
mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire ne naissent aujourd'hui la même
joue son épouse sur la scène du st
georges et les gentils gringo
périodiquement
je j'ai le bonheur de le revoir dans le
personnage de leonardo qui est une de
ces grandes créations dans votre domino
veni xviiie siècle les nardo
conservateur khabar et tyrannique veut
marier sa fille sans même lui présenter
son genre son épouse et ses amis
s'insurge et mompart ratage m pour que
les jeunes gens fassent connaissance la
quête incessante pas loin ray colère
sera terrible je vais la chatte y es tu
et l'humilie je vais je vais la brise et
même il faut bien quelques méchants si
ça doit entraîner ma perte
ouais un texte savoureux concentrer le
machisme de manipulation les hommes sont
loin d'avoir le temps vole ça fait
toujours plaisir d'entendre le bien être
du goût un malheur n'arrivant jamais
seul on ne va pas s'habiller on doit
pasqua fait on doit travailler j'ai rien
compris aux femmes
rien de la brute le succulent pprd cdu
galabru